that is a giant white shark being taken
in off the coast of nova scotia she's
been nicknamed
nagumi queen of the ocean nagumi was
tagged and released by osearch the
research and exploring team led by chris
fisher
who we've been following for years they
hope their latest trip provides new
clues on sharks who have made a huge
comeback in parts of the world
though the mystery of the great white
has not yet been fully
solved when you see these
big females like that that have scars
from
decades over their lives and multiple
mating cycles you can really
kind of see the story of their life
unfolding
across all the blotches and healed
wounds on their body
and it really like hits you differently
than you would think it was
nagumi is one of the largest great white
sharks
anyone's ever seen 50 years old
3 500 pounds the crowning achievement
of a month-long trip off nova scotia for
the team at osearch
we're getting pushed around all the time
the wind's constantly changing
after running from storms for 21 days in
the middle of this unprecedented
atlantic hurricane season
osearch was able to sample and release a
total of eight
white sharks on this latest trip
including nagumi
so-called queen of the ocean what are
you hoping she tells you in the years to
come
well she has a great opportunity of
showing us where the atlantic canada
white shark gives birth
that is their ultimate goal something
that has never been witnessed
along with so much else about white
sharks
if they thrive the system thrives if we
understand their lives we can help them
thrive
if we lose our white sharks there's no
food for our grandkids
the seals wipe out our fish stocks the
squid wipe outer fits fish stocks
and the white shark is the balance
keeper
and the path to abundance goes through
them osearch says they're satellite tags
which allow researchers to track the
sharks for five years
are a key to unlocking it all
tagging involves first hooking the shark
with a smaller boat
then gliding it into a large lift part
of an old crabbing vessel
as we first saw in the waters off cape
cod
eight years ago now that the shark is on
the lift this
is when the scientists do their work
osage tries to keep the sharks out of
the water for less than 15 minutes
during which they're sustained by a rush
of sea water secondary watch yourself
move
while blood samples are taken four
minutes 20 seconds
and the tag is put into its dorsal fin
which oserch says doesn't cause pain
because no blood or nerves connect to
the fin
okay tag's done from the first time we
were on the ship with you in 2012
what have we learned we knew almost
nothing about what the white sharks were
doing in the north atlantic other than
some of them were showing up in the cape
cod region in the late summer and fall
we started to put the tags out there and
the first thing we did was to find the
full range of the north atlantic white
shark we now know
that they're moving from atlantic canada
and newfoundland all the way down the
eastern seaboard and through and into
the gulf of mexico
as far west as the mississippi river
your methods have been criticized as
being too invasive why do you stick with
them
because that's not what the data says
when you look at the blood data and the
stress data it doesn't indicate that
when you look at the ultrasounds of the
animals when they're in the cradle it
doesn't indicate that
so i think that comes from you know the
fact that
what we're doing is orders of magnitude
greater than
anything that has been done in the white
shark space in history
we're studying the biology of the white
shark getting a complete picture of that
as well as the ecology of the white
shark at the same time
with 21 research projects by 31
principal investigators
from all these different research
institutions around canada and the
united states
are they out there right now yes they're
there fischer talked with us this week
on the coast of long island
another place that's seen an increasing
number of white sharks in recent years
they're around you everywhere you go
when you're on the water you know we've
been swimming with them our whole lives
the one thing that's changed since the
beginning of our work is
that we know that yeah finley looking
good old girl
finding out exactly where they live and
move is not only a key to keeping people
safe
it's critical for conservation efforts
not just here
across the planet sharks are in much
better shape than they were just a
couple decades
ago is there a reason for concern moving
forward beyond this
well sharks are in much better state
than they were decades ago
in the united states of america but when
you leave the united states and they
lack management and there is no
enforcement
uh it is still a super big challenge
which then affects the
global ecosystem of the ocean in very
very negative ways
if the united states is in such good
shape as you say and other places are
not
where to next for you where do you think
the worst situation is
well we're looking at several places but
one of the places we hope that we could
maybe
make a real difference is in the
mediterranean it's just been over
harvested since the beginning of mankind
it's had people around it since the
beginning trying to survive and eat and
so it's it's taken the brunt of
of our growth as humans
how do you turn that back around try to
get the white sharks moving in the right
direction start creating awareness
and hope that that impacts the fish
stocks the marine mammal stocks
and slowly you're talking about you know
we turned it around the united states in
20 years
i think there you're looking at more
like you got to have a hundred year
vision
wow 100 years 100 years 100 year vision
because things are so bad in the
mediterranean when it comes to sharks
right now
but it is just it's awe-inspiring to
stand next to one of these white sharks
on that lift glide your hand
i'd rather do it there than in the water
you couldn't resist you just
couldn't remember we spent time with
jeannie a few years back i wasn't able
to see
uh nagumi right in person but now we can
track her on the website for for the
next five years or so
and um and they're planning to go so
there's talk about going to the
mediterranean and then also spend some
time
uh maybe off the carolinas next summer
to try to find out more about
where they where they breed and where
they give birth it's great work and it's
every time we do a story like this it's
the reminder it's all interconnected
they're all interconnected and that's
the thing people have to keep in mind
top of the food chain that goes away
everything else does too